hey guys it is Wednesday here on it's
Grace and today I'm going to do a makeup
tutorial it is September the end of
September which means most of you are
back to school
I assume unless you're one of the three
percent of fifty to six year old males
that watch my videos in that case hey
dudes but if you're going back to school
and if you're a female or male that
likes to wear makeup I thought today I
would do a makeup tutorial specifically
for going back to school when you don't
want to go to school this is my back to
school get out of school makeup tutorial
and makeup tutorial designed to make you
look like this something that doesn't
look healthy or capable of handling
education on any level let's dive right
in here we go you're gonna take the cute
backs cool look you learn to do from
some other beauty guru on YouTube we all
have a different purpose and we're just
gonna use all the products that they've
told us as a society we should purchase
and say no to their traditional uses No
now let's get comfortable you look
stunning and genderly confusing sound
take out that stocking doughnut that
convinces people you have your [ __ ]
together and just let it grossly hang
beautiful now I'm going to take blistex
or that chapstick stuff that your mom
usually has but I'm not going to use it
for my lips instead I'm going to put it
on the roots of my hair so it looks like
I've been sweating all night maybe
breaking the fever may be growing some
weird kind of dirty gross cap disease
you're starting to look like a dirty
forever21 campaign and that's what we
want
now choose those makeup wipes and say no
to that makeup you have on your face get
it all off there and really scrub hard
really let people wonder if you're
having an allergic reaction
make sure you get into that eyeliner
mascara and really smudge it good and
don't forget about your neck is
embarrassing when your face doesn't
match your neck and we don't want to be
embarrassed we just want to lie to our
friends and loved ones
next when take this eyeshadow from
covergirl it's brown but I'm not going
to use it on top of my eyes instead I'm
going to use it under my eyes to add to
the sleepless illusion
like this eyeliner shadow eyeshadow
great talk next we're going to make sure
we got all of that gross lip gloss off
our lips and then we're going to take my
foundation that I love from Smashbox and
use it on top of our lips to take the
color away we kind of want to look like
powder remember that movie not the
makeup the movie powder next we're going
to take my mascara from Tarte maybe
we're going to use it on her face why I
don't know this seemed like a good step
but don't go overboard kind of blended
in with your makeup wipe so it looks
like you've been experimenting with
human growth hormones then some final
touch-ups on the hair should really
judge and get some water and sprayed on
your face so looks like you've been
sweating sweaty person's never healthy
get him in there rub the nose a little
bit so it turns red looks like you've
been having a red nose and there you go
the final look is complete you're not
going to school you're gonna stay at
home and live vicariously through
youtubers there you go there's my back
to school ghetto school makeup tutorial
hope this up I don't know guys if you
haven't heard yesterday I released a
small chapter of my book online for free
for anyone to read it's 20 survival tips
for living online I hope that you go
click the link down below and read it
and if you like it pre-order the book at
Grace's guide book calm and then you can
read a lot more chapters with words
similar to the ones that have already
been used in the chapter you'll read for
free if none of this sells you on a
self-help book written by me oh no what
will